the goal of this video is to take this
big hairy expression where
we are essentially dividing rational
expressions
and see if we can essentially do the
division and then
write it in reduced terms so if you are
so inspired i
encourage you to pause the video and
work on this on your own before we do
this together
all right now let's do this together so
this is completely analogous
to dividing fractions so if we were to
divide the fraction
6 over 25
by the fraction 15
over 9 we know that we can rewrite this
as 6 over 25 divided by 15
over 9 which we know is the same thing
as 6 over 25
times 9 over 15
and then we can factor the various
numerators and the denominators this is
2 times 3
this is three times three this is five
times five
this is five times three let's see
three in the numerator three in the
denominator and actually that's about as
far as we can get so then we'll have two
times three times 3
which is going to be 18 in the numerator
and then in the denominator we have 5
times 5 times 5
which is 125.
so we're going to do the exact same
thing up here but there's one extra
complication
we have to keep track of the x values
that would make this expression
undefined in any way because as we
reduce to lowest terms we might lose
that information but if we lose that
information
then we have changed the expression so
we have to keep track
of how we are constraining this domain
so first i can just rewrite this as
x squared minus 3x minus 4
all of that over negative
3x minus 15
and that's getting divided by divided by
this business
x squared minus 16
over we have x squared
minus x minus 30. now the next thing we
can do
is we can factor the various numerators
and denominators and think about which
x values could get us into trouble so x
squared minus 3x minus 4. let's see
negative 1 let's see negative 4
times plus 1 would be negative 4 and
then these would add up to negative 3.
so i can rewrite this
as x minus 4 times
x plus 1. rewrite it that way
and then i can rewrite what i have down
here i could factor out a negative 3
so i could write that as negative 3
times x
plus 5. and then i could
write this one here this is a difference
of squares is going to be x
plus four times x minus four
and then last but not least this one
over here let's see
if i have a 5 and a 6
negative 6 plus 5 is negative 1 negative
6 times 5 is negative 30
so there's going to be x minus 6 times
x plus 5. now before i go any further
the reason why i factored at that point
is now we can think about what x values
will get us in trouble
we know that any x values that make any
of the denominators equal to
0 that would be undefined so we want to
constrain our domain in that way
so we know for example that x cannot be
equal
to negative 5. that would make this
denominator equal to 0.
let me write that here so x cannot be
equal to negative 5.
we also know that x cannot be equal to
six
x cannot be equal to six and this would
also tell us that x cannot be equal to
negative five so i don't have to rewrite
that again
but we're not done so we've figured out
the x values that make
these denominators equal to zero but
remember we're also dividing by this
entire
expression here so anything that would
make the entire expression equal to zero
would also be a problem because you
can't divide by zero
so anything that would make this
numerator equal to zero
which was this numerator right over here
would make us
also divide by zero so we have to
constrain there not this numerator here
that one's fine that one could be equal
to zero that's comple you can divide
zero by other things
so let's see we could see that x cannot
be equal to negative 4
and actually x cannot be equal to
positive 4.
so now we've fully constrained our
domain and now we can proceed
so let me box this off right over here
and then we continue i can rewrite all
of this so we're going to have
x minus 4 times
x plus 1 all of that over
negative 3 times x
plus 5 and now i'm just going to instead
of divide by this i'm going to multiply
by the reciprocal
so this is going to be times and i'm
just going to take the reciprocal
x minus 6 times x plus
5 all of that over we have
x plus 4 times x minus 4.
and once again our domain is constrained
in this way but we see we have an x
minus 4 in the numerator now
x minus 4 in the denominator x plus 5 in
the denominator
x plus 5 in the numerator and now we can
say that this is going to be equal to
x plus 1 times x
minus 6 all of that over
negative 3 negative 3
times x plus 4 x plus 4.
so the way it's written now we would
still it's clear that
x cannot be equal to negative four so
this information
you can say it's it's already there in
this expression now that we've reduced
it
to lowest terms but this other
information right over here
this has been lost so if you want this
expression to truly be equivalent to
this expression up here
you would also have to say comma x
cannot be equal to negative 5
6 or positive 4. you could throw the
negative 4
in there if you like but that's one that
one's already
in the expression so to speak